today on our show we are gonna talk to
you
well rather you talked to us to talk to
you the Q's and A's yeah today I'm fat
man I'm Daphne well from the Batman I'm
Batman I'm Givens myth Adam luck
Renard's mark here had an idea he says
been slow news week he says she says say
slow news week he says and I says a slow
news week because a slow news week you
said we did that for about 20 minutes
then he finally said I got an idea
Twitter Q&A I'll throw questions out our
question answered Twitter universe hey
you have any questions for us and
they'll throw questions back at us
preferably lob them not overhand so we
don't lose an eye
no because I mean we are not athletes no
no I mean despite the fact that he's
wearing a hockey jersey I just dressed
the part not athletes
so underhand not even fast pitch yeah
let's get out of hand
yeah slow and low let yourself go so
what do you got we often put accusin a
let's start with will de la Fuente Jam
master w on Twitter and under the
hashtag ask Kevin mark he s new rumor
title on in d5 is called Indy and the
weapon of a god how would you do the
next Indy back to Bible artifacts North
Korean baddies there you go not North
Korean baddies fine because I feel like
Indy works best against Nazis okay being
the last movie they did was 19 150 or so
Nazis are all gone yeah but it's like
neo Nazis there's always that be Isaac
like [ __ ] and movie begin I don't know
I'm [ __ ] neo-nazi kerbin some
[ __ ] and Indiana Jones old man
Joel curb man that he beat in the death
and [ __ ]
you're like Indiana Joe I mean last the
Last Crusade the second about Indiana
Jones don't get involved I mean as we
know 19 last after the [ __ ] we're
going to pretend crystals
never took place we're going to pretend
that we are still within 1940s thick
he's too old to be for it to be you got
to do practice I know I mean listen if
I'm making me Anna Jones movie you're
recasting Indiana Jones honestly if I
make it that's what you do I'm going to
distance myself from my secretary just
come I'm John just ease off by himself
on this one kids I'm on my island here
because in his own house before I got at
least one more yeah give him another
crack of the whip I mean got it he's the
architect of our childhood he absolutely
is but we are going to get another
Indiana Jones
sooner or later while he's still [ __ ]
above-ground you know landing planes in
the wrong places you should be [ __ ]
allowed to crack the whip one more time
particularly without like you know kids
sidekick yeah I don't want another mutt
I don't think you could do Nazis do it
it's too late like it's where are the
Nazis coming the I'm not saying go to
Korea but I don't know what the answer
is but I don't think it's not I think I
got an answer to go I got an answer
thank you Indiana Jones versus satanic
cult
[ __ ] take all my money I mean it kind
of did that with the taking out the
heart right I mean I I will also say
that you can do Nazis in Brazil you
could do the notches on the run you can
have not you can have him working for
the Nuremberg Court you can have him
chasing Nazi war criminals you could you
could feel have Nazis even though it's
not World War two you got a point man
the same but maybe his mission is to
break into Spandau prison and kill
Rudolph [ __ ] yes I just wrote that right
here what if ah
Indiana Jones crossed with Bedknobs and
Broomsticks I'd such a grown man thank
you tenderly because that excited me so
much for you me so he goes to the Oliver
boom boom yeah bad take us to the Isle
of naboombu or just a Cessna could do
that too maybe trip down to the pant and
stop the kids are flying they're in the
bed he's taking the [ __ ] long trip
yeah man that's I would you're right you
could I do not when you look at the
movies that have worked robot Nazis -
how about of the rise of a road like the
[ __ ] motors of the Third Reich the
Fourth Reich and he's got to stop go
behind ZZZ yeah I mean this when those
movies work
there are Nazis when they don't work
there are no Nazis so I'm aiming for
Nazis last time they did the Russians
wasn't she Russian yeah yeah a little
dr. Jones
and I do feel like it's got to be some
kind of biblical artifact yeah bokya now
you got me if they're gonna battle the
[ __ ] heaven and hell and [ __ ] for
[ __ ] spear Destiny the Ark of the
Covenant boom my [ __ ] dick of Ages I
don't care what it is man but it's got
to have some [ __ ] religious bent
don't have to come from the Bible but
God come from some how about this
what is that were the twelve golden
plates of [ __ ] shirt hey the Shroud
of Turin could be an invisibility cloak
did you take that Disney so I got I just
I ain't my YouTube month otherwise say
in the shreditor and that be badass
because the Shroud of Turin was
discovered like what early seventies oh
yeah yeah so he be old enough at this
point and they'd bring him out of
retirement like we want you to look at
the shadow toon and stuff in it sorry
people like it's a hoax and [ __ ] but
he's like no this is real and then
they're [ __ ] people that you know
like we don't want people know about
Jesus and a cutting throats and [ __ ]
like that
Coptics I'll throw that in there the
Coptic sounds dirty seven [ __ ] sexy
and then and then there's like satanic
cult I'm gonna still try to forgive that
in this league that it's not just all my
god trying to raise the dead Adolf
Hitler with the power yeah man like the
best Metallica album you never heard oh
my god and this guy's got nothing but a
whip to defeat the ultimate evil mm-hmm
picture
ah the devil go straight back to hell
wow you think it goes right thank you
hey belongs in a museum he's yelling at
me is it me with a whip good old
Manchester my museums at the top of that
Hill ah there it is there's our nd5 done
benjamin cat the real Benjamin cat you
and I reappears with the [ __ ] frauds
out there he asks Kevin mark will we get
a fat man on Batman live around the San
Diego comic-con this year to worry y'all
let you answer that one give him a
single because it's dramatic
a bad rummel Ching ah yes and back to
2-shot specifics are still being
developed yeah there's probably look for
it at the American comedy club but yes
we'll definitely be doing fatmata Batman
where are we doing another one
someplace lives we're doing one in st.
John Nova Scotia we're going out to Nova
Scotia yes to the maritime Sun we're so
far out off the time clock that there
are completely different time zone half
an hour different from these coasts
right yeah what yeah what kind of
witchery witchcraft is being [ __ ] the
altar time I only have an hour they live
a half now in the future
put the [ __ ] I know you could call them
up for lottery numbers would be a
billionaire tell me who won jeopardy
it's like having Biff as your friend
with the sports Almanac but for like six
hours yeah I think that's in August so
if you want to come to your [ __ ] neck
of the woods and do a show let us know
yeah we let him know yeah
tell somebody Twitter I got a hashtag
you know go to Jordan Monsanto let her
yeah she's the one who makes all those
exams she'll bring us to you all right
mm thing else on Ali Kevin Conroy mr.
Kevin Kammer I can't imagine this is
become I don't believe it is at that
little research uh they asked if you
could do dinner for five today who would
you choose and why
oh good question I thought was wonderful
unfamiliar folks at dinner for five at
the [ __ ] there's a TV show Jon Favreau
used to host on IFC where he collect
four different people would take him to
dinner and they'd shoot both them
wonderful I got to host it twice and for
my panel I picked I got toes at once of
course I can't remember I was on it
twice I got the hosted one I got to pick
on my panel Jason Lee Stan Lee Mark
Hamill and JJ Abrams wow that's a good
panel
good panel so what would I do today
who's on your who your for that you're
inviting along dead or alive or just a
lot I think was do a live like it's
tomorrow tomorrow at Bravo said you know
what [ __ ] it let's bring this show back
what does Real Housewives in wherever
who I want to talk to
like Bill Murray
nice good pull Barack Obama
ooh D Donald Trump incendiary just you
know what I'm saying
there we go good conversation at that
table or somebody's going to punch that
[ __ ] in the face gonna be a hell
of a night to remember Hill Murray would
hit him and too much of a sausage party
we need a lady in there [ __ ] I got one
lady to pick yeah just 52 percent of
population dude ah pick me a giveaway
too many slots at the table maybe I
should recuse myself from the table and
buy two ladies oh oh okay who did you
ladies man
ah he's made it twice and offered a bad
one so let me have some big uptick
Laverne and Shirley the lemon year-old
and me was like wait a second who what
lady would I like to mm-hmm show and
claim oh thank you good job
yeah I had dive deep on that one but
what a life she's live and you know you
get the old past life thing so I was
interesting that's like seven guests for
what exactly exactly go we have to feed
what and you know and [ __ ] terms of
endearment backstory and stuff like oh I
[ __ ] me and Deborah bought like [ __ ]
like that let me tell you all this [ __ ]
Warren did when he was a kid
bang oh my god she's a gift that keeps
on giving down that's not bad
there he goes pretty good town that's a
very good panel I don't know if I could
pull it together but that's mine and I
won't even change my dream pounds the
one I just came up with off the top man
yeah and also wouldn't have to be your
job to pull it together that's right you
just had our people then I will put the
show together I'm just gonna be the guy
who's eaten going
Oh mm-hmm yeah but talk too much
yourself
I just before the fat guy does all right
let's see last Rhonda's papers from
Bradley White at Bradley white he asks
what are your thoughts on Robert
Rodriguez directing the new escape from
New York Film and who should play the
lead what do I think about I'm doing it
I think Roberts a wonderful director and
in a world where someone's gonna remake
that movie give it to Robert Rodriguez
someone is gonna remake the movie kids
used to have to deal with that and when
I say kids I mean [ __ ] people our age
we're like we're gonna figure that so
it's gonna happen might as well give it
to somebody who we know could shoot the
[ __ ] out of something has a bit of
reverence for the genre and the actual
source material so I'm all great with
that as for who should play Snake
Plissken as you know I like man is that
guy'll know his name but he was in Logan
as the bad guy he's all on narco Boyd
Holbrook that's his name his name see me
ladies I hope he is not at all no
relationship no relation you know who
were just talking about uh-uh Snake
Plissken give damn yeah charming is [ __ ]
okay I like that guy would you give it
to um I kind of even though even with
the stink of Jonah Hex on him
I feel like Josh Brolin could do with
the job I think I feel look I like Josh
Baum but I think he'll be just he'll do
Snake Plissken impression like we've
already seen the baggage let's see the
difficulty on someone who's charming
like hey I'm Snake Plissken hi everybody
I'm slippery like a snake I'm gonna get
you out of here we're gonna escape from
New York what's Jim J Bullock doing J
blow yeah Snake Plissken all right what
do you got now let's see there we
answered your questions now mark
scottson I got some cinnamon buns who
asks and spelled sin with si any yes and
man and buns with Z asks what Marvel
character or characters do you think
would be a great would be great for a
new Netflix valve series and who would
your casting choices be Marvel character
Marvel characters / characters
fool-killer
who yeah yeah I mean have to dig geeks
but I didn't Eve at all fool-killer
pretty great [ __ ] Marvel miniseries
back in the day written by Steve Gerber
I believe I would do fool-killer deep
cuts right there but you know in a world
where they're doing [ __ ] power fist
and power Power Man and Iron Fist like
they're down Oh
superheroes why not why not fool-killer
I say sure [ __ ] it um how about you I
would do damage control which I think
they're kind of doing and I mean
spider-man right that's kind of the
others but Michael Keaton and his
buddies are kind of damage control but I
would absolutely do the you know sitcom
version a lot of uh parts are they doing
that on NBC powerless is gate to the DC
version of that but it's more like dudes
in a lab inventing [ __ ] for superheroes
less than it is cleaning up after the
mess that superheroes make oh so
everyone get in trouble with marvel
because Marvel I think if someone was
developing a damage control show and him
John Ridley was gonna do it well I think
that might have been indefinitely put on
hiatus happens in the way things happen
when they don't kill like my entire
career and definitely put on my with
dancing and but yeah I would do that I
would do that I would do it too and
watch you do it [ __ ] you do this
while you did it power fist in it yeah
alright we got two questions from good
kid Paisley Park greedy son of a [ __ ]
absolutely good short short T three one
eight yes good kid pays very yeah okay
what moving slash shows are y'all
anticipating this year is his first
question what movies all obviously every
comic book movie I'm anticipating in a
big bad way and then shows the defenders
we saw a teaser for I was like fifteen
fifteen I was like a [ __ ] thirty
chicken my father here you were a
butterball yeah as I cousin stuff a
roaster me my my pop and I was ready to
was ready he I am looking forward to
baby driver the Edgar Wright the Edgar
Wright jimmy-jam because I dude like
makes a movie in the way that you
absolutely know it's in a droid movie
yeah he's got the cinematic syntax to
the point where you absolutely know
every time you turn on the oh [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] right movie he's doing that
thing that he does which is hyperkinetic
super involvement music you know and and
sort of deep treatments of characters
that are not ordinarily treated deeply
so yes I'm all on board for they be
driver shows welcome to if Edgar is
wrong I don't want to be right with Mark
Bernard
Kevin Smith cultivators shows I will
also say the defenders primarily because
I don't know very much about what's
coming in the back half of the year
besides the fact that I know that
defenders is coming in August August
eighteenth scoring Weaver's the bad guy
yes but despite whatever misgivings I
might have had about Iron Fist it is I'm
hoping a bump in the road
I finished Iron Fist yeah having to
watch all 13 episodes we'll talk about
all right fair enough
see ya that's they gave me [ __ ] on
Twitter like you review to you Roger
ribs is like I said up front I've only
lost three episodes I'm talking about
three episodes he had watched more I did
and I got to it I got [ __ ] after doing
them after six and then we're dealing in
after 11 I went all the way though I
took it all the way so I was bad to the
person a second question from good kid
hey how fist thank you because should
have come to me for the opening title we
spent way too much money on that [ __ ] I
would have been like this central voice
ready how well this and then put the
words up and we're good to go Philly a
flashlight in your sleeves so just like
a little bit right now that's why we
were to be out writing better
for the addition of like $3 I made that
work so like both of you get out
oh not part of a [ __ ] what reboots less
remake that I enjoy that nobody else did
the Saint Balcombe er caramel picture
remake on back to the 90 going back to
the 90s we make of the old Roger Moore
show from the hands Simon Templar I'm
exemplar rogue thief who does the right
things for reasons that remain unclear
to almost everybody but him national
disguise tech wizard James Bond light
basically the that's the reason why
Roger Moore gets to be James Bond is
because he was so good in the sink he
was like the same any play the same and
you like the movie we don't come if
Daffy and silly and crazy but it has a
goofy [ __ ] energy that I can't get
enough of alright right question should
we flick at the question but being that
I ask feet and Leander repeatedly asks
who got that domain name so good for you
Pete yeah what would you think about a
netflix hulu amazon show based on the
question as a gritty crime action slash
drama i would think it'd be amazing
wouldn't it down yeah i wonder if anyone
ever worked on that before i don't know
I mean I'm sure they worked for a while
long and hard mmm give it some real
thought hmm a couple roadblocks along
the way there was a point where me and
Mark were working on a question thing
for the powers that be
you want two brothers one above those
and it didn't didn't Carolyn you know
for reasons that still elude us above
and to the left of my paygrade
I think it has something to do with the
fact that like there's a you know the
character came from Charlton comics and
when they bought them they don't know
how many rights they had if they had
cinematic rice bobble that's what I was
heard but I think the question would be
amazing I've been trying to get it done
for a while so somebody should hope
Internet yeah
let's see Andrew
gray yeah a good way you guided us at
Twitter so I keep going do you guys have
favorite video games you played to play
the Batman Arkham series and what are
your thoughts on that medium of
storytelling well my favorite video
games was The Adventures of Rocky and
Bullwinkle for Sega Genesis Wow
played it all the way to the end beat
that [ __ ] is one of my favorite
properties in the world Bullwinkle and
rocky done as a video game he could beat
Boris badenov and Tasha loved it one of
my other favorites was remember Super
Nintendo did like Superman game but not
the [ __ ] one that everyone's like
this is lame he's like where he fought
doomsday it was like the [ __ ] the
death of storyline and the multiple
Superman's
I came so [ __ ] bad guys let's see I
haven't played any of the Batman Arkham
games you know they're worth to play I'm
not been told they're amazing but it
seems like a big commitment of the time
you got to give it you know somewhere
between 20 and 30 hours I've watched all
the cutscene so then you you've done it
yeah I'm not into like let me slide xxy
be just show me two cuts yeah I'm on a
button mash not I'm too old for these
fat fingers can't button mash I'd be
bite mention what about you I am a gamer
I am still a gamer not nearly as much as
they used to be when I could develop
hundreds of hours so like Final Fantasy
and Metal Gear Solid but I think I say
something nice about some video game on
Twitter's
here's a game I just finished playing
called horizon zero dawn which is the
sort of Poker post-apocalyptic game
where humanity has been pushed to the
brink of extinction and then managed to
claw self back in a world where now
there are robotic animals roaming the
plains and it delves into this super
deep story and this apocalypse about
like wipe my money what happened to
humanity what happened with the animals
why are there robots run extensions all
over the place and it's a beautiful game
the mechanics are really strong and it's
also this this really progressive world
where the leaders is a young one
and most of the power structures are
matriarchal it's an incredibly diverse
world where you know and it's it's all
like made-up tribes and so when it's on
but it's kind of refreshing to look at a
world in a video game that looks like
the world that we live in or the world
that some would like to live in yeah
it's great and I love a deep story game
one of my favorite games I've ever
played was Red Dead Redemption Rockstar
Games and as the Grand Theft Auto
Western but it's an open-world westerns
you get a horse you can ride almost
anywhere you're in Mexico you're in the
states you an Arizona so it's like
what's cool
it's like West world except you know
robots just actual just Western but yeah
and it's a heartbreaking game like by
the time you get to the end of that game
there's literal tears it's an affecting
video game narrative really yes there is
unbearably mark thanks it is an
effective story time
totally like that's it's it feels a bit
like television in that way that you can
tell a story over time and space that
you can't quite do in a movie you know
and then you can tell stories that
involve character choices and player
choices that would branch into different
ways that you couldn't do any other way
so choose your own adventure game where
you also get to kill people there you go
sounds like a free ad right there videos
red blue red dead redemption i Debra
dead dead Red Dead we just you know Tom
Baxter it is see but let's do good the
jacket man and leather jacket man what
is your writing
what are your writing processes like
home or work set up for example what are
you write I write it on I get up good
answer by office play a joy let's light
a joint [ __ ] a dick and and start
writing yeah my brothers how long do you
write for so I'm done okay until
something else is like hey you got to be
at this thing I'm like ah [ __ ] and I
leave at the time I'm supposed to be
there because I was writing sometimes
you enjoy writing so much you just want
to see where it's going without planted
out so as I'm writing the conversation
or scene it's unfolding you're like oh
my god what's gonna happen so sometimes
I stick around for that see what's gonna
happen what's your you know says oh my
process is an evening process I'm
Nightbird you're a knight rider' I'm a
knight rider' my my my my my my my my
Knight Rider all right Martin I think up
way too late right listen
well yeah usually it's like the wife and
kids are in bed by like 11 o'clock at
night and I go to my office and then
night for an hour and a half two hours
every night let's just Peter out I would
like the freedom to do more but because
I got a day job and I got to get kids
off to school and I got to do all of
that stuff and ends up being grabbed it
when I can grab it I also don't mind
writing out in the world but you know
there's some times when I'll go to a
coffee shop or I'll go to a bar I like
quite like writing in bars or something
there's something nice about angled
single single is single disc because you
want it they stopped doing that in TV
production you may know there's two go
single you don't get to use the director
you know to put your hands into somebody
else's shop but Tom tell them about that
but I like I like writing and I like the
white noise of speech I like writing in
bookshops I should do a lot of writing
rather than in Jersey to Barnes and
Noble hundred thirty-five mm-hmm because
I got to used to do yeah because I like
a I like people I like being surrounded
by words like the word just a finger to
my brain I get into words and I like
writing in bars because I like nursing a
drink and letting that sort of just
break things me ask you this do you get
when you're out of out of Barnes Noble
or whatever to get a lot of what are you
working on or no almost never really
almost nobody gives a [ __ ] I'm even
sitting there [ __ ] right in the code
that will destroy humanity nobody cares
I mean more often than not especially if
you're living in New Jersey when I was
writing in Barnes & Noble they don't
know what a screenplay looks like true
you know out here everybody knows and
everybody's doing it themselves but
baby's heart it's a guy it's just
working out saying maybe the spreadsheet
I can't tell a lot of words you rent a
novel they didn't know that you were up
to you were making you a dream and I was
dreaming mom Martin listen to me madam I
work at The Dream Factory
and I would like own a say Hollywood
well yes I become more they
catch-as-catch-can writer um let's see
Leonard Maxim let's close out with this
all right Leonard Maxim dies or Daly's
2:18 on Twitter says favorite guilty
pleasure movie look who tempted to say
Baba food oven they do know I am going
to say Cooper ain't nothing like a
Hollywood stuntman stuntman something
that is a duper Burt Reynolds our son
I'll meet him with Jan Michael Vincent
as the kid yeah ends with a sick [ __ ]
car stunt yeah but I remember seeing
that movie at like 11 or 12 and be
entirely entranced by that life by the
like here's a broken man who straps on
his gurney and it's [ __ ] leg brace
and the Pops of pills and drinks the
beers just to go out and make pretend in
Hollywood yeah and that pretend in
Hollywood cost him pain I love that
movie
yeh stole the fall guy from that right
yeah pretty much pretty much oh yeah I
have seen some they did but still I'm
not jumped from the tall building all
times and from my thigh
but I'm the UH no snow it makes the
Eastwood book so fun yeah it's right
when we were kids we love stunt people
yeah [ __ ] because what a great job you
get to like I'm gonna fall out a window
pretend I'm dead
it is everything a kid has ever wanted
to do like you get to just jump and play
and throw punches and nobody ever gets
hurt except you totally get hurt drive
real fast drive backwards down [ __ ]
highways paths and beers to your friend
when drinking and driving was it that
you could put in a movie that kids could
possibly watch this
I mean where Oh Sally Field on it - yes
she was the love yeah yeah she's a love
interest um Wow
I wouldn't even call that a guilty
pleasure I call her a pleasure pleasure
yes pure pleasure
mhm pleasure my pleasure and other
people magic what is my guilty
pleasure let's see it's annoying to
something I'll do it above no I think I
just make guilty pleasures I've got a
guilty pleasure left the dream of all
dreams though and unsellable dream so
I'd live mom I don't know I can't think
of anything that to me is like you know
back in the day I remember I used to
watch the cutting edge clip it new topic
yeah topic which is such a guilty um but
I don't know what a guilty pleasure
would be at this point you see concern
movie that that if you're flipping
channels that you will automatically
stop at if you see no no not just yeah
we're in visually so it's like Bobby's
going through channels and I'm like oh
[ __ ] I going Gary Glen Ross I have that
digitally I just click over to the other
thing now I mean oh I wouldn't consider
them guilty pleasures but I love those
old pilot eh movies I think I prefer
them to the new player of the explosion
hmm
I understand they spend a lot of money
on the new ones but not a billion
dollars but a lot of money a lot of
money but um but rubber masks you still
got me believing I don't stop believing
just because it's not a rubber mask but
still yeah well no I got um guilty
pleasure I don't think I mean that's
also fair because I think that you take
pleasure from you need not be a thing
you feel guilty about it's true there's
really nothing [ __ ] even when I jerk off
that's not guilty pleasure
that's proud pleasure like I'm guilty or
there's there's natural all there's
nothing to think my mom's like tiger
just chat put it away
look at that mother natural I'm playing
I'm playing Bob straws and in the
background for your mom while I do it
what's your sing guilty yeah it was her
and [ __ ] there you know huh and we
got nothing to do bigot yeah mother like
I let Emma thank you so yo did come to
get whistles I mean that's what they
were
basically they're thinking about 70s
disco soul of a second victim
my mom would listen that I'm all the
time so thank you okay so now next time
my mom plays our song in the [ __ ] car
I'll be like ma you taking about sucking
seventies dick she's like I love dick
and seven son
that [ __ ] was huge I mean get baby cable
do this
can we go quiet a mile try a barrel you
just sing and she was like humming
[Music]
basically I wanted you have any
one-year-old woman driving around
Florida dreaming of a better day
better days and better days god bless
america ah there you go man we've
answered your question
don't say we didn't know he did we'll do
this again sometime Monday if you're
good you're back one day the news is
lean yeah maybe around Christmas for
Batman Batman I'm Kevin Smith I'm mark
barnard come back next time we'll say
some more [ __ ] right here in the fact
cave save fat time save fat channel
SModcast calm for YouTube there comes
less killing Smith
[Music]
you
[Music]